hallo mein name ist zu kommen die ersten
drittel bereits entnehmen können gucken
wir uns heute das reichste mädchen der
welt an und dafür schauen wir gemeinsam
das video ein tag im leben der jüngsten
milliardär in der welt wenn kylie jenner
hat ein geschätztes vermögen von circa
einer milliarde euro bevor wir uns das
video allerdings anschauen werfen wir
wie immer einen kurzen blick in die
kommentare wie 22 selfmade
milliardärinnen mutter eigene firma und
so weiter ich 22 mama kannst mit
kartoffelsalat oder tomaten machen
selfmade denn die einer anderen familie
geworden wäre hätte sie nichts die
tochter hat mit drei jahren mehr
klamotten lässt sich in meinem ganzen
leben zwölf mate ist für mich ohne
sponsor oder eltern was erreicht zu
haben kind kommen wir gehen in diesen
auto laden kylie raus aus meiner garage
ich könnt ihr aber zu viele operationen
in dem alter alter was für selfmade der
ihr vater war reich und ja wir sehen
schon die kommentare gehen weit
auseinander
ich würde allerdings sagen wir starten
jetzt mal das video
[Musik]
wären 220 aber nicht wissen wie man die
eigene wäsche rest ja kein scherz das
hier ist die selfmade milliardär in
selfmade sei wirklich mal dahin gestellt
dies ist allerdings kein wunder denn
obwohl sich kylie jenner inzwischen
milliardäre nennen darf ist sie gerade
einmal 22 jahre alt
ich wusste schon mit 14 wie man eigene
wäsche wäscht und damit nicht nur die
jüngste milliardären auf diesem planeten
sondern auch die jüngsten
selfmade-milliardär in aller zeiten
sie ist also ein einmaliges phänomen
aber wie kommt jemand im zarten alter
von 22 jahren zu einem solchen vermögen
berühmte familie reiche eltern bevor wir
auf den genauen tagesablauf von kylie
allen gehen werfen wir einen kurzen
blick auf ihre bisherige
lebensgeschichte haile wurde im august
1997 dies eineinhalb jahre jünger als
ich
und ich stehe hier in meinem kleinen
zwölf quadratmeter aufnahme zimmer und
quatschen der kamera und die ferraris
durch los angeles als tochter von ex
zehnkämpfer bruce jenner und der tv
persönlichkeit kris jenner geboren
daran sieht man ja schon die eltern
waren extrem berühmt also ich weiß nicht
wo das self made ist sowas wie mark
zuckerberg finde ich die selfmade na gut
weiter geht's als sie gerade mal zehn
jahre alt war
da
sein
dass das ist ja ein komplett an
der mensch so begann sie mit gerade
einmal 14 jahre
das ist das ist das
in meinen augen ein komplett anderer
mensch mit gerade einmal 18 jahren also
im jahr 2005 da sieht die halt echt gut
aus
das muss man halt sagen aber das ist
halt auch alles nicht natürlich mit dem
kylie liquid brachte sie also ihr erstes
produkt auf
das ist für ihn david
und nicht die männer im alter von 21
jahren vom forbes magazin als
milliardären eingestuft zu werden und
damit nicht nur eine der berühmtesten
personen in ihrem alter sondern auch die
reichste person in ihrem alter zu sein
ist das auf keinen fall aber man muss
wirklich man muss den vollsten respekt
zollen für diese kylie lipstick
geschichte weil milliardären
das sind 1000 millionen als kylie 20 war
bekam sie nämlich mit rapper travis
scott außerdem ihre erste tochter ihrer
35 millionen dollar teuren luxus villa
die wie die anderen willen ihrer familie
in einem stadtteil von los angeles
namens hidden hills liegt
35 millionen neben dem duschen und
frühstücken ist ein wesentlicher das
sind alles die kleidungsstücke von dem
von dem kind ich kann dem kommentator
zustimmt so viel habe ich jetzt
mittlerweile gerade auch noch nicht in
meinem schrank ich muss allerdings auch
mal kurz sagen dass ich auf das video
von kylie jenner selbst wie ein tag in
ihrem leben aussieht schon reagiert habe
auf meinem kanal also meine reaktion auf
die junkies das glaube ich habe ich das
schon darauf reagiert allerdings möchte
ich mir dass sie trotzdem weiter
anschauen weil dieses überreden von
diesem moderator so vielleicht kommt da
noch was anderes zum zum vorschein infos
passion so noch nicht angewandt was ich
meinen also wir schauen weiter so wird
sie bevor sie aus dem haus geht von
ihrem eigenen make up artist und ihrer
hairstylistin gestylt ich glaub mir nach
dem duschen einfach ein bisschen gehlen
jahre v 3 sekunden die hat ihren eigenen
make up stylisten und her
dies milliardären niemand vernünftigen
satz raus sogar ihre tochter story hat
mit nicht einmal drei jahren schon ihren
eigenen begehbaren kleiderschrank das
war
wohnung dann beginnt für heidi der
arbeitstag dafür nimmt sie eines der
zahlreichen autos ihres privaten
fuhrparks und der hat es in sich denn
kylie jenner ist berüchtigt für ihre
automobile unter ihren autos sind neben
einem bugatti skiraum mit 1400 ps und
einem lamborghini aventador auch
insgesamt drei mercedes amg 63
du kannst du kannst du nur ein auto
fahren war also ich verstehe es wenn
leute sagen ja ich hätte gern ein auto
so zum spaß haben so ein bisschen
rumcruisen und so weiter und so fort und
dann nochmal eine familienkutsche g
klasse oder so wenn man irgendwo
wirklich hinfahren will mit mehreren
leuten aber warum braucht man 10 20 km
insgesamt fünf verschiedene ferrari
modelle zwei range rover mehr als fünf
rolls royce und sogar zwei oldtimer
nämlich ein vintage rolls royce und ein
alter muster sind
15 caron die sie hat
es ist völlig legitim kai die durch all
diese teuren autos kommt ihre sammlung
auf einen wert von über 14 millionen
dollar
ich fühle mich
mit zunehmender dauer dieses videos
beschützen habe mit einem dieser autos
fährt sie an einem üblichen tag dann in
das hauptquartier ihrer firma in oxnard
kalifornien obwohl sie milliardären ist
bedeutet dies dass sie gut 40 minuten
jeden tag in ihr büro pendelt wie wär's
mit einem helikopter oder so
die hat da 14 millionen autos und ich
kurz vor der kamera
dafür hat sie im bürogebäude ihrer firma
sogar extra ein spielzimmer für ihre
tochter einrichten lassen und ein
miniauto besorgt mit dem
all natural häufig wird die 22-jährige
milliardären allerdings von kameras
begleitet zum einen da sie
logischerweise noch immer regelmäßig in
keeping up with the kardashians zu sehen
was
das läuft noch die serie
das wusste ich gar nicht ich dachte das
lief halt früher einfach aber seit den
einigen jahren jetzt wo die kardashian
so unfassbar enormen erfolg haben und
alle irgendwie selbstständig unterwegs
sind dachte ich dass die serie abgesetzt
wurde so weil irgendwie diese kendall
ist ja am modeln heidi macht trust mit
14 millionen euro autos rum die anderen
die anderen kenne ich nicht aber auch
weil sie mit live auf kylie inzwischen
sogar ihre eigene fernsehsendung hat die
seit 2017 im us fernsehen läuft
keeping up with the kardashians keeping
up und kylie
dies alles vor die tür
die am anfang schon angedeutet haben wir
nun aber noch eine interessante
neuigkeit über kein okay denn
tatsächlich hat die unternehmerin mitte
november 2009 10
anteile von ihrem unternehmen im wert
von 600 millionen dollar verkauft
ist sie deswegen milliardären ja und
zwar an den kosmetikkonzern coty der der
deutschen investoren familie reimann
gehört
die deutschen
maschine nach amerika einkaufen hier die
ganzen make-up kacke davon kylie auf
damit hat keine insgesamt 51 prozent
ihrer anteile an kylie cosmetics an die
reimanns abgetreten somit hat sie ab
sofort nicht mehr die alleinige
entscheidungsgewalt über ihre firma im
gegenteil im zweifelsfall kann sie bei
allen geschäftlichen entscheidungen
überstimmt werden
hätte ich ehrlich gesagt nie gemacht bei
dem unternehmen für das du mit deinem
namen halt stets ein weiterer punkt ist
auch dass kylie selbst immer wieder in
interviews darstellt dass sie als junges
mädchen sehr unsicher war
da sie ihre lippen nicht schön und ich
das sind wirklich zwei komplett
verschiedene menschen tatsächlich stammt
ihr vermögen zwar zum großteil aus einer
firma die sie selbst gegründet hat
allerdings konnte keine cosmetics nur so
erfolgreich werden
da kann die durch ihre familie schon als
kleines kind zu einer nationalen
berühmtheit in den usa wurde ist genau
das was ich gesagt habe und hier das ist
wieder ein komplett anderer mensch
einfach allerdings muss man ihr auch
lassen dass sie dennoch viele kluge
entscheidungen mit kay cosmetics
getroffen hat ja damit will ich das
heutige video auch beenden ich habe
wirklich vollsten respekt davor was
kylie jenner sich aufgebaut hat und wie
sich kay cosmetics entwickelt hat uns
weiter und so fort man muss allerdings
wirklich sagen es ist nicht selfmade ich
könnte das voll aber
ich glaube die hat es nicht geschafft
wenn sie da nicht rein geboren wäre gebt
dem video auf jeden fall gern einen
daumen hoch schreibt immer und in die
kommentare was ihr mit einer milliarde
euro machen würdet und ihr findet jetzt
hier einen smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr
darauf könnt ihr kostenlos main kanal
abonnieren dadurch verpasste keine
videos mehr wie beispielsweise ich wie
ich nicht richtig reden kann
also klickt da drauf wenn ihr noch kein
teil der lupus seit und hier findet ihr
ein video verlinkt das soeben auf meinem
zweit kanal online gegangen ist
da gucke ich woher youtuber wirklich
kommen also